put your car in reverse and say hello to
my little friend because it's the season
finale of American Horror Story
apocalypse in this episode sure to tug
on your heartstrings
Myrtle swags in to deliver a package to
mutton Jeff but has to get past the iron
gates that are miss Venable she doesn't
have an appointment and it looks to
venable that she could use an
appointment with mr. Cowell instead when
Venable questions how Myrtle got in she
snaps her fingers and falls under her
trance she explains that purple is for
royalty not middle management a callback
to episode 1 when Venable explains
Purple's in the bunker are the upper
class in their office mutton Jeff go
over there outpost rosters mut assign
them to outpost 2 which is all the smart
people in it but Jeff is like WTF why
the hell aren't they in outpost 4 with
Jennifer Lawrence and Scarlett Johansson
if you pause the video you can even make
out one of the names in the outpost is
simply a woman mut asked who they're
gonna put an outpost 3 which I can only
assume is the one near Los Angeles
according to this map Michael wants the
battle-ax 9000 they are aka robot Mead
and her memory erased this explains how
me didn't know she was a robot and had
no recollection of Michael or her
massacre of the witches Myrtle strolls
in and confronts dumb and dumber
noticing the outpost survivor board
rather than deny their plan mutton Jeff
immediately tell her that the apocalypse
is happening mutt takes the pistol the
same one used by the masturbating robot
hand intending to kill Myrtle but she
manages to put a spell on him she tells
them when mr. st. Pierre Vanderbilt
calls asking for four seats to give him
the tickets we met mr. st. Pierre
Vanderbilt Coco's father briefly in
Episode one and later in the season when
he donates a large sum of money to get
cocoa in - Robi shows to harness her
extreme power of detecting gluten back
at the swamp
Cordelia updates the witches on the
gravity of the situation Michael is too
powerful and no witch could possibly
stop the thousands of nuclear bombs that
are about to go off they go over the
outpost plan to buy Mallory enough time
to pull off tempest infinitum the
ability to change the past
then comes the identity spell aka how do
we justify all the crazy [ __ ] that's
gonna happen in a three-minute scene of
exposition Cordelia is gonna put this
spell on them so they'll forget they're
all witches be given new identities and
personalities which explains why cocoa
was such a [ __ ] in the first three
there's a fire right there [ __ ]
and even worse koco's family won't be
joining her Malorie has dealt stating
that she doesn't think she can be
responsible for the lives of 7 billion
people the weight of the world is
literally on her shoulders well not
literally more like metaphorically you
get what I mean
KOCO and Malorie won't remember anything
until the spell is broken
even Cordelia they say their goodbyes
and KOCO even gives Mallory a pre
apology
this is the writers attempt to make us
not absolutely hate Coko because let's
face it who can love this maybe you can
see if you have a superpower that allows
you to shut your piehole and get back to
work Cordelia blows some fairy dust at
them chanting in Latin water is the
memory of time and the spell seems to
work as we're transported to a few
months before the apocalypse at first I
thought this was the day of the
apocalypse since KOCO had her hair
appointment with mr. Galan just like in
episode 1 but it's actually way before
that since we get to see her first
meeting with Brock her future fiance
Madison and ready drops the witches off
when she sees a bus advertisement for
the dynasty Van Show remember how Dinah
made a deal with Michael to let them
into the coven if she got her own
successful talk show KOCO is in need of
a serious hair overhaul but Brock chimes
in it's a complete waste of time since
you can't improve on perfection
Cordelia struggles with her decision
when Madison storms in she wants
permission to burn a witch Madison has
put two and two together stating the
only way Dinah could have possibly
gotten her own show was if she made a
deal with the devil
Myrtle says it makes sense because Dinah
double-crossing them was her only way to
get a ticket to the outpost now this is
a bit weird since at the time of the
double-cross the plans for the
apocalypse and the outposts weren't even
known to Michael or Dinah nor had the
cooperative undergone any of the prep
for them so big question mark on that
Myrtle agrees that Dinah must go but
Cordelia is the voice of reason they
can't do anything that could possibly
alert Michael and jeopardize their plan
she'll pay in time we're then treated to
the same scene from episode 3 where
Mallory unleashes her power on Michael
during the interviews for sanctuary this
is an interesting scene to put here
because it doesn't give us any new
information about Michael Mallory nor
does it further the plot
Cordelia Myrtle and Madison emerged
post-apocalypse after being buried for
more than two
years in the healing Louisiana mud
Cornelia exclaims it's time and were
shown the witches arriving at Hawthorne
aka
outpost 3 which was the end of episode
three the two timelines are finally
about to converge Malory Dinah and cocoa
are released from their identity spells
when they are interrupted by Michael
this was also the beginning of episode
four he exclaims he can't be beaten
after all he's already won the
apocalypse has happened Michael has
reshaped the world and his father's
image but Myrtle reminds him he forgot
the most important rule he must get rid
of all the witches this explains in
Episode three when Michael has his
one-on-one with Daddy after the incident
with Mallory how he thought he killed
them all and in a turn of events Michael
offers them mercy in return for their
obedience which i think is a bit out of
character since the beginning of episode
eight sees him swear that he'll kill
them for burning me the only person who
ever loved him in his life Cordelia
lovingly responds by saying the only way
they'd sit at his table as if his
decapitated head were the centerpiece
and Dinah once again betrays the witch's
saying she always chooses the side of
the winner then were treated to the
return of Marie Laveau the former voodoo
queen from season three at the end of
that season her soul was taken by Papa
Legba but Cordelia has since arranged a
deal Marie's soul for one far more foul
and suited for hell Dinah's she takes a
machete to dine his neck proclaiming the
trash
Cordelia short-circuits meat who goes
bonkers like the lady from Total Recall
Michael is blown away next to headless
mean and a fun homage to alien geez how
many times was this guy watches mother
figure die Madison goes all Scarface and
shoots the living crap out of Michael
with Meade's robot arm killing Michael
Myrtle takes a personal item from
Michael so that Mallory can lock on to
it and perform The Tempest infinitum but
in order to cast it they'll need to find
someplace safe because bullets alone
won't stop the Antichrist for long
madison offers to hold him off so the
others can safely escape to perform the
spell and holy [ __ ] it's radioactive
Brock who stabs Mallory in the gut seems
he's still bitter about not being on
that plane
and brach learns the error of his ways
because when you [ __ ] with a witch you
get burned Michaels blood seeps back
into his body and with a clench of his
fists completely explodes Mallory's head
I guess it's back to retail food Elia
tries a healing spell when they're
interrupted by Marie who tells them
Michael is on his way she holds him off
allowing the others to escape telling
him he can't pass Marie goes all badass
saying he's dealing with the head [ __ ]
in charge before her heart is brutally
torn from her body
Coco stabs him in the back and as easily
as he snaps his fingers her neck is
snapped - Mallory is brought into a tub
where Cordelia and Myrtle champ trying
to get Mallory back to normal
but it isn't working and Myrtle says
what we're all thinking we're [ __ ]
idea Cordelia confronts Michael calling
him a little boy probably because on the
inside a part of him really is remember
how we magically turned from a boy to a
full-grown man in one night
Cordelia does what she's known deep down
she's had to do all this time kill
herself so that her powers can transfer
to Mallory this was alluded to in
episode 9 in a process known as the
sacred taking Mallory's fart tub Jacuzzi
erupts and it seems as though things are
working using this new burst of power
she invokes tempest infinitive and
descends into the water were then
transported back to 2015 in the murder
house when Constance was in charge of
looking after Michael she freaks out on
him because he's been killing everything
lately even the local priest Michael
tells her he doesn't want to be this way
he needs help
but she's not having it this isn't some
innocent murder phase that all kids go
through it's only gonna get worse
Constance kicks Michael out telling him
never to come back when Michael snaps
and chokes her and if this day couldn't
get any worse he's hit by a car by none
other than Mallory who repeatedly runs
over him Constance rushes to his
grandson's aid who requests he'd been
taken back to the house where he can
live with her forever
but Constance tells him to go to hell a
fitting use of words considering his
satanic origins and look how screwed up
his feet are here damn still in 2015
Mallory applies to be a witch at Brobee
show but this time she knows she's from
the future everyone else is oblivious to
the apocalypse which she has
successfully prevented but because the
apocalypse was stopped Cordelia didn't
have to resurrect Myrtle so she's too
debt a small price to pay for seven
billion lives Queeny tells her about her
planned trip to the hotel Cortez which
she got trapped in and Michael had to
save her from and Mallory warns her not
to go and makes up some silly excuse
about being far from the beach
Madison is still in hell and Mallory
lets her stew there a bit longer and
look it's nan lovable nan and Misty who
Mallory was able to spring from Hell due
to mad street cred with the demons for
killing the spawn of Satan
banan decides to go back because of her
love for Papa Legba we then fast forward
to 2020 where we see Emily protesting
until she bumps into Tim remember Tim
and Emily everybody yeah these two
characters who really didn't serve any
purpose to this story other than for
exposition on how the buffer works then
they just die we never see them again
yeah those two well emily is protesting
outside a coffee shop and if you
remember from episode one that's how she
made her way into the bunker she was
arrested for protesting on campus and
taken from jail by two men in suits Tim
he makes a joke about how he's point O
seven percent Brazilian because of an
ancestry DNA test which also lines up
with how he was caught in the bunker the
co-operative found him because of the
blood he took for that test and damn
that didn't take long
emily is having a baby and I think it's
safe to say it's Timmy's were then
transported three years into the future
where Tim and Emily are concerned over
how angry their three-year-old is check
out the sky here which is oddly similar
in hue to the sky found around Michael
near Murder House there's even a murder
of crows up above Emily asked if they
had money for the baby sitter when Tim
finds a blood stain on the wall their
child has killed the babysitter just
like young Michael did when he was three
years old in season one oh and look
who's arrived
it's the Satanist honey as were brought
under the realization that nothing in
this season mattered now I might get in
a lot of [ __ ] for this but here's my
take on this season and know that my
critique comes from a place of love deep
in this hollow heart of mine overall I
love this season with some minor
exceptions like Episode eight this
entire season was building up to an epic
battle between Michael and the witches
and what did we get the son of Satan
getting hit by a car a car no magic no
battle no anything just a Range Rover to
make matters worse we find out that none
of it mattered the witches went through
all this trouble and we went through ten
episodes only to find out that
everything is futile because another
spawn of Satan will just take
Michels place but that's not to say that
journey wasn't fun I had a blast of
season breaking down these videos for
you I just wish it had a more satisfying
ending I might even come out with a
video and how I thought the season
should have ended but enough about me
what do you think I want to hear your
comments below did you like the season
the ending hit me up with those hot
takes is that what the kids say nowadays
I'm hoping to come up with one or two
more AHS videos before starting on a new
show so also let me know what shows or
movies I should do next keep in mind I
like to do current show so I know some
of you have requested me to do previous
AHS seasons but I'm gonna hold off on
that a bit for now thanks again for
watching and for being with me this
season make sure to LIKE subscribe and
share and until next season remember
daddy loves you very much